un nouveau mandat pour rester dans la
continuité
le collectif ensemble pour magny les
hameaux se lance dans la campagne
municipale autour de bertrand ou lyon à
la tête de la commune depuis 2012
un engagement collectif autour de quatre
grandes orientations solidarité
participation citoyenne bien vivre
ensemble et transition écologique
transition écologique c'est ce qu'on a
déjà entamé sur la commune s'est
continuée transformer notre commune pour
pouvoir l'adapter et lutter contre le
changement climatique
c'est des éléments qu'on a déjà commencé
en terme de rénovation de du des
équipements publics en termes de run run
as-tu ration de la ville en termes de
diversification agricole pour une
alimentation locale plus saine en termes
de mobilité avec les circulations douces
et nos interventions vis-à-vis de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
d'ile-de-france mobilité pour avoir plus
de bus plus d'expression des ateliers
citoyens sont en cours pour finaliser le
projet si la liste des 29 nom n'est pas
encore totalement établi bertrand ou
lyon repart avec un renouvellement de
50% de l'équipe je les rejoins parce que
je pense qu'il y a quelque chose à faire
au niveau solidarité au niveau
associatif au niveau intervenait
générationnel dans la commune
et puis ce qui m'intéresse
particulièrement aux 6 et c'est une
ouverture
parce qu'il est bonne idée de partout
est ce que propose le maire sortant
candidat c'est si justement allé puiser
les bonnes idées le collectif ensemble
pour magny les hameaux propose un nouvel
atelier citoyen mardi 21 janvier à la
salle des festivités
deux autres candidats se sont déclarés
sur la commune de minutes grattepain
élus de la majorité de 1995 à 2001 et
lionel lindemann actuellement membre de
l'opposition